a former President Barack Obama had
instructed public schools last May to
let transgender students use the
bathrooms that match their gender
identity and he actually threatened to
withhold funding for schools that didn't
comply Donald Trump's administration
yesterday revoked that guidance to
public schools allowing transgender
students to use the bathroom of their
choice
this reversed the initiative of
Democratic President Barack Obama Trump
said during the campaign that he didn't
care about which bathroom transgender
people used in no uncertain terms let me
remind you what Trump said which is the
complete opposite of what he has done by
rescinding this guidance yesterday
remember this said I heard one of the
best answers I heard was from a
commentator yesterday saying leave it
the way it is right now to happen not
very few problems leave it the way it is
North Carolina what they're going
through with all of the business that's
leaving and all of the strife and and
that's on both sides you leave it the
way it is there have been very few
complaints the way it is right people go
they use the bathroom that they feel is
appropriate there has been so little
trouble and the problem with what
happened in North Carolina is the strife
and the economic I mean the economic
punishment that they're taking so I live
in a that's general people working in
your organization I don't know not
really don't know I probably do I know
he does those who have Caitlyn Jenner
were to walk into Trump Tower and want
to use the bathroom you would be fine
with her using any bathroom she chooses
that is correct okay and yet and yet now
Donald Trump has rescinded those
guidelines even though they were put on
hold by a federal judge
anyway arguing that state and public
schools should be able to make their own
decisions without federal interference
so some important things these are
guidelines that Obama put out that Trump
has rescinded this is not law the
guidelines are not law but let's skip
that for now anyway okay the defenders
of Trump are saying there's no double
standard here nothing to look at Trump's
policy is a private business owner in
his building that people use whichever
bathroom they want is different than
saying that there should be federal
permit guidance on policy Trump saying
hey I can make the decision I want at
Trump Tower but schools should be able
to make whatever decision they want some
people are calling this an in-between
position that that's BS the in between
position would be do nothing and allow
the legal system to figure it out we
talked about hyper partisan or divisive
issues issues that really only serve to
divide and often those are issues of
very little consequence but they really
fire people up and this is one of them
this really shouldn't be an issue in
cities in the u.s. definitely in New
York for years somewhat in Boston in
most of Europe bathrooms are laid out
with a common sink area an individual
stalls period this goes away as an issue
it's just not an issue you could say
well schools are organized differently
where you have a men's room and a
women's room two responses to that
number one again even in those scenarios
you don't have any problems coming up
when you allow people to use the
bathroom that matches their gender
identity and number two
maybe we should continue moving in the
direction of gender-neutral bathrooms
anyway well I think it is harder parts
Donald Trump doesn't really care about
changing the policy when it comes to
transgender bathrooms I actually think
he's rather socially liberal but I think
he also has many conservatives in his
ear I mean CPAC is this weekend he's
trying to up his conservative
credentials sure so I think that's what
this comes down to and anyone who said
that he would become more moderate
especially on social policy if he got
elected there proven wrong by now it's
quite the opposite no doubt and it is
because of who's in his year we know
that whatever he was most recently told
is what he goes with you want to know
the real issue with letting people use
whichever bathroom they want the
bathrooms labeled as men's will start to
have longer lines reminiscent of the
bathrooms labeled as women I'm joking
but that's really if you were to say to
me what would be your number one
observation about how things would
change
it would probably some be something as
innocuous as that I'm glad that Donald
Trump has finally addressed the national
security threat of transgender people
using a bathroom now I guess we can deal
with Isis healthcare immigration
education
jobs climate change and energy now that
we have bathroom usage out of the way
just absolutely pathetic today's program
is made possible in part by movement
watches @m VMT watches comm I'm wearing
my movement watch here one of the cool
things about movement watches is not
only was movement watches started by two
Broke college kids in a dorm room pretty
similar to how the david pakman show
started
they also utilized crowdfunding
similarly the david pakman show has
utilized crowdfunding to grow what it is
that we do and now movement watches has
sold over 500,000 watches unlike equally
slick-looking watches at department
stores which can cost four to five
hundred or even more dollars movement
watches start at 95 bucks and you can
get 15% off today as a David Pakman show
viewer or listener by going to nvm T
watches dot-com slash Pakman not only
will you get 15% off you'll get free
shipping as well as free return so again
go to mV mt watches dot-com / Pakman